PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
A subscription
can use either the Push
or a Pull mechanism
for message delivery.
But which one makes sense
for your application?
Stay tuned to find out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Welcome to "Pub/Sub Made Easy."
I am Priyanka, and
in today's episode,
we will learn to pick the
right delivery mechanism
for our Pub/Sub messages.
In the last episode, we
learned that in Pull delivery,
Subscriber application initiates
the request to the Cloud
Pub/Sub to receive messages,
while in Push delivery,
Cloud Pub/Sub initiates the
request to the Subscriber
application to deliver messages.
How do we choose
between Push and Pull
mechanism for our use cases?
Well, let's look at
this step by step
by comparing a few properties.
What kind of endpoints are
needed for Push versus Pull?
Well, in Pull mechanism, because
the subscriber is pulling
messages from Cloud
Pub/Sub via the API,
any device on the internet
that has authorized credentials
to call the API can
serve as a Pull endpoint.
In case of Push
mechanism, the message
is being pushed by Cloud Pub/Sub
to the subscriber endpoint,
so the endpoint must be
reachable via DNS name,
and have SSL
certificate installed.
It should be a
non-self-signed certificate.
The benefit of
Push subscriptions
is that they are largely
decoupled from the Pub/Sub.
They don't need to have
credentials or use the Pub/Sub
client library.
They just need a bit
of application logic
that knows how to parse
Pub/Sub host request body.
It's a very lightweight
integration model.
How do you balance load
while using Push versus Pull?
Well, in Pull mechanism,
multiple subscribers
can make Pull calls to the
same shared subscription.
Each subscriber will receive
a subset of the messages.
While in Push
mechanism, the Push
endpoint itself can be a
load balancer distributing
the request to the
right back end.
The real use case for this
Push model is front end,
multiple subscriptions
pointed to the same endpoint.
So as you add new topics, you
don't have to change anything
about your subscriber.
How do you control
the flow of messages
received by the subscriber?
What if the subscriber cannot
handle the messages fast
enough?
Well, in Pull mechanism,
the subscriber client
controls the rate of
delivery-- because, you know,
it's the one pulling
those messages.
The subscriber can
dynamically modify
the acknowledgment deadline,
allowing message processing
to be arbitrarily long.
While in Push scenarios,
the Cloud Pub/Sub server
automatically implements
the flow control
by backing off
exponentially whenever
the endpoint returns error, or
takes a long time to respond.
There's no need to handle
message flows at the client
side.
Although the client can
indicate that it cannot handle
the current message load by
passing back an HTTP error.
When it comes to
efficiency and throughput,
Pull mechanism achieves
high throughput
per CPU and bandwidth by
allowing batch delivery
processing and acknowledgments.
The downside is
that you must always
have an application running
to keep getting messages
from Pub/Sub.
With Push delivery, you can
take advantage of the scale
to zero serverless pattern
supported by Cloud Functions,
Cloud Run, or App Engine.
This is useful when your request
rate is low or very uneven.
The Push mechanism delivers
one message per request,
and limits the maximum number
of outstanding messages.
Now, to the most
important question--
which mechanism is best
for your application?
Well, here goes.
You would typically
set up Pull subscribers
if the volume of
messages is large--
like, many more
than 1 per second.
If efficiency and throughput of
message processing is critical,
and if public HTTPS endpoint
with non-self-signed SSL
certificate is not
feasible to setup.
And it's recommended
to use Push subscribers
if there are multiple topics
that must be processed
by the same webhook, with
App Engine standard and Cloud
Function subscribers, and if
you use an environment where
Google Cloud Platform
dependencies,
such as credentials
and client libraries,
are not feasible to set up.
All right, so today
we learned how
to choose between Push and
Pull subscription models.
We compared the set for
endpoint, load balancing,
efficiency, and flow control
for Push and Pull subscribers.
These are factors
that play a role
in finally deciding
which model to choose
in your specific scenario.
Join us next time to learn more
about setting up the subscriber
to receive messages
using Pull delivery.
If you like this video and would
like to see more such content,
don't forget to Like and
subscribe to our channel.